hey what's going on everybody it's jon
bam bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team i just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that i bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something i'm i'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further we're
going to introduce a patreon community
and basically what that means is if you
become part of this community look i
already bored bam bam if you want to
become a part of this community you're
going to be able to hear episodes early
and all that ad free and all that good
stuff but there's all this behind the
scenes footage all this stuff that we've
shot
that really brings you into the folks
that we've had on the show really brings
you into their world you're going to be
able to do live chats with me and the
folks that i bring on the show to talk
about their world talk about the issues
that they're dealing with about their
triumphs and their tragedies just go to
patreon
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
was um something about building bridges
and and bringing people together and um
bringing folks that often don't get the
mic and giving the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tune in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll